joining us now ranking member House
Intelligence Committee Republican
congressman Devin Nunez it is now
inevitable congressman it's not a matter
of if it is a matter of when we have
talked about five separate buckets we've
talked about the FISA applications 302s
gang of eight exculpatory evidence and
more now the president is Declassified
this is a game changer and the IG report
and mr. Durham and John Ober and the
Attorney General tell us what you see
unfolding and when well I want to start
by making sure the American people
understand what Moeller did yesterday I
think you've done a pretty good job but
people also forget one important point
Moeller tried to do this victory lap he
tried to talk about the Russians that
they found in the Russians that they
prosecuted I just want to remind people
that the House Republicans on the
Intelligence Committee had that over a
year ago and Moeller if he's so
concerned about these Russians why did
they obstruct our report from getting
out so our reports still heavily
redacted Sean so you know Muller didn't
get the exactly right he lit he lit the
fuse yeah the president can declassify
that too and you asked about what should
come first I mean I think the thing that
should come first is number one we still
don't even know what Muller was supposed
to be investigating we don't have that
document we know that he's talked about
conspiracy to collude well when he
walked in the door he knew there was no
evidence of collusion we know that
because his lead investigators said so
on text message he was so depleted
dishonest yesterday that he says well
the the office of legal counsel says
that you can't indict a sitting
president well he should have been done
after day two he has no Russians except
for the fusion and Clinton Russians and
possibly the dirty cops at the fbi's
Russians those are the only Russians
that he has that show connections to the
Trump campaign clearly the Clinton
operation is heavily working with
Russians or Russian disinformation
he didn't take time to look into any of
that and then you have this that he
comes and says well there was there was
no possibility to indict the president
obstruction of justice so you just have
to ask yourself sitting back
thinking about it what was that press
conference all about yesterday what was
this answer your own question not one
thing and that was just a light
light the fuse for impeachment because
these guys are in big trouble another
important point let me point what do you
in the molar box he had to clarify so
with the joint statement what does that
mean
well that was bar actually being a
growing up and had to probably remind
molar hey we've got you on the record
three different times saying that you
were not that you didn't have enough
information or evidence to indict on
obstruction had nothing to do with the
position of the office of legal counsel
so we clicked but there's another
important point that that I think that
people should remember about and that is
that you had Comey with diarrhea of the
mouth yesterday in the Washington Post
he said something about Mifsud Mifsud is
the guy that supposedly knew about the
dirt on on Clinton the professor in
England yes he called them a Russian of
the other professor he called him a
Russian asset now remember in the molar
dossier molar stopped short of calling
him a Russian asset so now you could the
former FBI director who started this
investigation can't even can't even get
in full communication with the molar
dossier people and then just just to
finish up and put a you know put a final
point on this Weissman and you were just
talking about this in your monologue
Weissman and another attorney there
handled the steel dossier in August of
2016 now are you telling me these are
these are high-level people Bruce or
Andrew Weisman and and the other
attorney that worked on them on their
molar dossier team are you telling me
that in August these guys they're
sitting there looking at this very
salacious and unverified information and
not one of them sits there and says um
where did this come from Bruce or where
did this come from
oh my wife's doing it my wife's working
for fusion GPS that's working for the
Democrats in the Clinton campaign I mean
the whole thing is it's laughable but
it's it's so serious that you have
trouble I mean you you want to laugh but
at the same time you just hope that
justice is actually served to these
criminals if you listen though to the
Attorney General when he went before
senator Graham
committee is he interested and wanted to
get to the bottom of the FISA abuse we
know that Bruce or behind closed doors
testified yeah he warned everybody
Hillary paid for it
Steele hates Trump and by the way it's
unverified that was in August of 2016
ten days before a State Department
official Kathleen Catholic also warned
them before
call me signed off on the first FISA
application it says verify but it's a
nun verifiable document because steel
doesn't stand by his own words are those
people going to be held accountable do
you see any way they get out of what I
would think would be an indictment to
commit fraud on a FISA Court an
indictment to literally rig an
investigation into their favorite
candidate Hillary Clinton and then to
use Russian lies to take down a duly
elected president they get away with
that
well I think the easiest thing to
prosecute on are the leaks and the line
and obstructing Congress's investigation
what I would say just in closing is that
is that if you look at what's happened
in this whole investigation you've got a
lot of areas for the Department of
Justice to look at don't forget about
the State Department also you've got the
dirty cops the State Department and
whoever from the Clinton campaign was
was working with the dirty cops to get
information from Russia you starting on
a real investigation would it be fair to
say when the American people see what
you have seen it will shock the
conscience and soul of this country well
I always say on the on the FISA
application especially that you know
you've heard Comey call it a mosaic and
it's just playing yeah people need to
see what's there because I think they
would cringe if they knew what the
government was willing to do to its
citizens all right Thank You congressman
we appreciate